La Russie regarde le scénario
attaque terroriste à Zabari
administration à un acte terroriste avec
bénéfice rayonner C'est tout pour les petuvalas
corps
[musique]
chanson
la livraison a lieu 30 enregistrements
150 donc encore 500
un enregistrement ici
[musique]
Je ne peux déjà rien mettre de trop et
compte tenu de cela, je ne peux pas dire de quoi il s'agit
effrayant aussi
J'avais même peur au début
c'est à grande échelle et toutes les informations sont envahies par la végétation
Oui, j'ai vu
Des checklists circulent sur les réseaux sociaux concernant
plan d'action Que faire Où aller
Eh bien, je n'ai pas couru pour l'iode, pour être honnête, eh bien
ce sera bien, comment pouvons-nous en avoir peur
asseyez-vous et donnez vos cheveux et pour que
plus loin Si c'est destiné alors c'est destiné Sinon
alors ça n'arrivera pas, mais comme si d'avance
courir quelque part, faire quelque chose que je ne vois pas
sens
[musique]